>> Marv: LET'S GO DOWN STAIRS TO
JARED GREENBERG.
>> Jared: I GOT KEVIN DURANT
WITH ME.
BEFORE THE SERIES STEVE NASH
SAID THAT YOU HAVE TO OVERCOME
THE NEWNESS.
HAVE YOU ACCOMPLISHED THAT?
>> NO.
I THINK WE STILL GOT A LONG WAYS
TO GO.
THIS IS AN AMAZING TEAM ON THE
OTHER SIDE WHO I KNOW THEY WILL
COME WITH IT.
>> Jared: WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU
LEARNED ABOUT YOURSELF?
>> WE PLAY HARD, TOGETHER.
GOOD THINGS HAPPEN FOR US.
>> Jared: TOMORROW WILL MARK TWO
YEARS SINCE YOU INITIALLY
INJURED YOUR CALF.
I KNOW YOU WORKED YOUR BUTT OFF
TO GET TO THIS POINT BUT DID YOU
THINK YOU'D BE THIS GOOD?
>> IS THAT A REAL QUESTION?
OF COURSE.
WHAT YOU WANT ME TO SAY TO THAT?
OF COURSE I DID.
>> Jared: IT IS IMPRESSIVE WHAT
YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I WILL GO TO PRACTICE AND WATCH
FILM AND SEE HOW TO GET BETTER
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT